[Music]
where this week as you can see it is
just me for those who don't have Twitter
dream did tweet out that he's taking
some sorry there's gonna be a lot of
that happening the dogs do not listen to
me when Julian is not enough so there
will be barking there will be dog
fighting there will be peach
relentlessly kissing him
but Julian had tweeted the other day he
is he's having a hard time right now and
he would love to be here but it's
important that he takes some time and
takes care of himself and yeah he
Julian's okay
all of your well wishes have been really
appreciated for him but it's sometimes
you gotta take care of yourself so I'm
just gonna have Jenny chill time just
like Julian would do for me someday if I
needed to just you know shut off so my
apologies for those of you that come
here for fire segways and Julian time
hopefully he will be back soon
and please bear with me because this is
obviously the first time I've ever done
the podcast alone Julie has ever done
the podcast oh we've never done the
podcast without each other
so my segues are not gonna be fire at
all but this podcast is brought to you
by Squarespace
whether you need a domain website or
online store make it with Squarespace
if Squarespace is good enough for Keanu
Reeves John Malkovich and musician Leon
bridges it's damn good enough for you
you know a dream is just a great idea
that doesn't have a website yet make it
a reality at squarespace.com slash jana
Julian it's also brought to you by ROG
sponsor me undies me and E's is cutting
into your legs Hulu super sweaty that's
been my underwear situation forever
until I found me undies
me and ease are the best most comfy
underwear you'll ever own and your butt
will love you made from a sustainably
source and actually soft fabric that is
three times softer than cotton they're
the ultimate feel-good undies for when
you just want to feel naked but not be
naked so you can go to me undies comm
slash Jenna Julianne that's me andis
calm / - Jenna and Julian they're also
backing themselves Mandy's is so sure
you will love their underwear they offer
100% satisfaction guarantee if you don't
love your first pair get a full refund
right now you get 20% of your first pair
and free shipping if you have 20% off
free shipping 100% satisfaction
guaranteed Mandy's calm / Jenna Jillian
thank you so much sponsors and also with
Squarespace sorry my bed I'm not good at
this this is Julie's job he does this
all the time he's so good at it
Squarespace comm / Jenna Julian
you'll save 10% off your first purchase
of a website or domain squarespace.com /
Jenna and Julian thank you so much
sponsors for always being there for us
even in the weirdest of weeks when it's
just Janet chill time you know what I'm
saying
so I asked on the Jenna and Julian
Twitter what you guys would like if I
were to just sit down and sort of have a
chill cast and you guys tweeted a bunch
of things at me it seemed like a lot of
you guys wanted like life advice and
stuff like that which I am more than
happy to do I also gathered together
some Craigslist missed connection
through you because although that was
like such a joke a lot of you guys have
been requesting those they're very
difficult to find because some of them
are just downright sexual and creepy in
nature but I did find some some of them
like I don't think I can read them all
the way well we can do that somewhere in
the middle you know just have a nice
little break talk about some connections
in case you know you out there and you
just you miss the love of your life
somewhere on a bus or some [ __ ] but in
terms
of this weekend basically we've just
like I've been sort of taking care of
Julian and he's going through a lot
right now and we sat down and watched a
movie for like the first Simon forever
because a lot of you guys know that we
have been heavily heavily [ __ ] with
pub G which is a video game that we play
on PC and we streamed often on Twitch
but that's like what we do every night
you know it's like four years for me it
was like oh you know you get your dinner
ready and then you're gonna go watch
Survivor you're gonna go watch your
favorite show or some reality show or
whatever just something like you know
light-hearted and we don't do that
anymore
like we'll catch up for like on TV shows
when we're getting ready to like go to
bed which is why we end up like with all
these episodes of one show to just binge
watch at once because we'll just miss
weeks in a row because we'll just be
playing pub G and we haven't been
playing for quite some time and also
part of that is we don't watch any
movies like ever
because if we're gonna watch something
we'll binge watch like a show we miss a
bunch of episodes of and we don't want
spoilers and stuff and it's never movies
but I know a lot of you guys tell me -
you're like sometimes your videos are
really silly and funny or like the
podcast made you laugh because you're
having a hard day and you just like need
that and we did that with Julian this
weekend he was like I want to watch Coco
no one's like hey oh yeah we even watch
the movie you have a dog so I feel like
a lot of you guys make fun of me too
because I just don't I don't see movies
like I'm not gonna see a movie unless I
know it's like amazing cuz I don't want
to invest that much time but I will
invest you know 50 or 60 hours into the
curse of Oak Island without any regret
or problem but if it's a movie somehow I
deem it as a waste of time if it's bad
or if I don't like it
but we watched Coco and that was just
such a nice movie and I really like I
couldn't tell you the last movie that I
watched I really don't know but it was
something animated it was probably
like I don't know I don't want to
embarrass myself I don't know Thor I
don't know I don't remember the last
time I went to the movies I don't know
is that bad
I think that's bad but anyways you guys
tweeted a lot of stuff at me and you're
really sweet for doing that because who
the [ __ ] has a podcast by themself
you feel me Dawg this is just comfy
Chinese chill time because usually when
Jillian's here he dictates all the rules
like a Marla to use this voice we're
singing that or else he gets really
upset and pissed off and the dogs aren't
allowed to sit on the table but guess
who's sitting on the table all [ __ ]
three of them is absolute psych actually
I love having them here they're really
well-behaved they're really well-behaved
when they have mats and things to sit on
and little cushy happiness but if
they're on the ground right now come it
would be scream crying and marbles will
be barking at the door because they
don't listen to me right guys but
daddy's not here we get to do whatever
we want which is podcast together but
I'll just jump into some of this stuff
that you guys wanted to know I guess
because I mean as much as I'd love to
have a system where you could call in I
don't I don't we don't have that you
don't have anything to do that you know
there's no way for you to do that
without calling my personal cell phone
and I think that would create some
problems you know I'm saying
this question is from Kay booty a talk
about retaining your youth as an adult
woman I feel like it's so easy for men
to quote act like children when they're
out of their 20s but for women we're
expected to grow up so soon I feel like
this would be such an interesting
conversation topic that all of these
questions are like to think for a second
retaining your youth as an adult woman
okay I don't like I'm not trying to
spill tea or anything
right now but I was watching a person on
YouTube who was slightly older than I am
she's a woman and like I feel like you
do this like multiple time start your
life right you compare yourself to your
peers people in your same age group and
I'm 31 years old
and a lot of the people my age are the
well that I know are like married they
have kids or like you know people I grew
up with or went to college with or you
know take themselves very seriously they
take their careers very seriously their
jobs their lives and this person I was
watching on YouTube is like not that
much older than me but just like her
whole demeanor her whole everything is
completely different than mine which is
really nice and really cool but I also
think that some of my friends are people
that I've known in the past like they're
sort of always like that you know like
the the girl in your school that was
like the head of her sorority or like
you know took some some something really
seriously those people grow up to be
serious adults and you know a lot of
people like myself included like might
be immature for a while you might be
like a crazy person for a little bit but
you know you sort of level out as you
get older and I really I understand the
expectation of women needed to grow up
and that we do in our society give men
this likely way to sort of [ __ ] around
because they're always just gonna be
dummies that's sort of what our culture
teaches us you know and I do feel that
pressure that grown women need to act
like grown women but I just totally
think that it's a state of mind and
retaining your youth to answer your
question I think it's just a mindset
because I looked at people like the
woman I was talking about on YouTube or
other women that I see on YouTube and
I'm just like man you're great and
you're wonderful but I just do not and
that's not me that could never be me and
I look at women like my mom and I'm like
there's just people in this world that
will never take life that seriously
I mean like this it's just a spiritual
thing it's something that's inside of
you that will always keep you young no
matter what and I think it's just a
mindset in a state of mind and it comes
with rolling with the punches of life
and just like riding the wave letting
the wind blow you just being a little
bit more of a free spirit and I do think
that that's something you can learn how
to do you know for all the people that
are wound up really tight and they don't
want to be I think that you can sort of
learn how to be a little more
open-minded or free-spirited because
like I was a weird kid pretty sure my
mom can vouch for that but like I'm very
cautious and very rational but you know
as I've gotten older I'm like you know
what doesn't [ __ ] matter is like you
know a laundry list of things I think
that it's something you can become you
know even if you're a grown woman and
you have grown women responsibilities
you can still become a little more like
you know what [ __ ] it [ __ ] everything um
but I do understand that pressure of
being a grown woman versus a grown man I
do think we give men in our our American
culture a little more leeway to just be
like dummy dum-dums sometimes at a
certain age but also in Los Angeles it's
a little bit of a different thing
because people just never grow up here
that's like their that's their solution
everything is like a lot of people just
never grow up oh that's a weird weird
thing to say man but yeah I mean to
answer your question I think you can
identify that as a pressure and you can
be that or you can just always sort of
have a free spirit about you while still
accomplishing your responsibilities you
know I'm saying it's the state of mind
and the less [ __ ] you give the easier
life is I promise you okay Emily purse
says I love when you talk about growing
up in upstate New York like all of your
fav places and food and your fav
memories my favorite places in food
when I was growing up in Rochester New
York we didn't have like a lot of chain
restaurants and stuff like we had
fast-food places like McDonald's Burger
King and places like that and we had a
Italian restaurant called Mario's I
think it was which was like lit is [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying like probably
not the best food in the world but like
on a Saturday night like Oh dad's house
weekend we gonna [ __ ] Mario's thing
we gonna get some spaghetti no idea if
it still exists there
also there was a obviously ate meat
growing up and one place that we used to
go to as well like more in high school
was this place called country suite
which is really delicious [ __ ] fried
chicken and waffles and that kind of
thing that was sort of my first exposure
to the deliciousness that is fried
chicken and waffles and we make
alternate versions of them now sure
pretty delicious with country sweet was
[ __ ] bomb because we didn't have
Waffle House or Roscoe's or any of that
stuff also a place that holds so many of
my memories I don't know how big of a
chain restaurant it was or if it still
exists but it was a Mexican restaurant
called Chi Chi's and I feel like there
were so many birthdays that Chi Chi's it
was just like one of those things it's
just that restaurant in town where
you're like [ __ ] it we'll go to tea geez
they would give us these paper sombreros
and like it was just like slightly above
shitty Mexican food like not great not
though it's just solid you know what I
mean we would just go to Chi Chi's when
the [ __ ] gimme you know and I feel like
growing up too like we my parents had
joint custody of us basically food split
time and every other weekend we would go
to my dad's and now as an adult I
realize like my mom would always cook
for us and like do all this stuff that a
mom would do you know like have a son a
real schedule routine and then we go to
dad's house and we would stay up late
and watch cartoons and go to Chi Chi's
and I realized I was an adult that's
like think of all the times when you
just don't want to feed yourself at all
like I'm so hungry but I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna do [ __ ] right now this
that is like yes and I'm sure someday
I'll get there too but it's like [ __ ] it
well govern it geez you know what I'm
saying that was Chi Chi's and there are
such good memories to be had there um
I'm sure you guys all have a restaurant
like that that you can share with me
because I'm really interested you still
exist but oh man my dad will let us get
like virgin strawberry daiquiris and
stuff and like all this is so naughty
like they give it to you in a margarita
glass this is why I stay up late and eat
snacks like cheese and salami and a
whole sleeve of Oreos if we wanted to
like basically if we just wanted to eat
ourselves sick we could but we didn't
you know but the option was there which
was great that's what dads are for you
know what I'm saying
kidding Oh idolize underscore re asks as
a psych major I'd love to hear about
what valuable information you learned
slash experiences you had during your
education although that may not be as
interesting to everyone who isn't as
nerdy as I am so a lot of people want to
ask like questions and a lot of people
ask me on Twitter too a lot of you guys
are curious about college like education
questions which is interesting to me
because I'm now like 10 years removed
you know
like somebody could probably give you a
better answer that I could give you and
it's just my experience valuable
information you learned and experiences
you had during your education so I think
this is so stupid but I feel like the
most valuable lessons that I learned
throughout my education were all
experiences like they weren't you know I
don't remember specific lessons that I
learned were like dude I've retained
this knowledge for 10 [ __ ] years man
changed my life like absolutely not I
absolutely do not remember how to do all
those statistics classes that I took
half the math that I learned is just
gone goodbye
do not know how to do it anymore and a
lot of the electives that I took don't
remember I couldn't even tell you some
of the classes that I took in college
don't remember but what I do remember is
like my internships that I had I think
played a big important role in shaping
me at that age and playing sports and
being so dedicated to that team at that
time and like you know playing a role in
a team I think plays a big part in your
life and maybe that's not a sports scene
maybe that's your year into music or
you're into a certain club or art or
whatever it is that you're into learning
that experience as a young person I feel
like played a much bigger role in the
rest of my life then my specific classes
are specifically what I learned and I
also felt like I had a college
experience you know like everyone sort
of teaches you that undergraduate it's
gonna be this like you're going off to
college and like you're gonna figure out
who you are and you're gonna discover
yourself and you're gonna make friends
to last for the rest of your life and
like sorry like some of that is true
some of that is true like up for me
personally you know I did walk away from
college with a handful of friends that
I'll probably always be friends with and
I did have some experiences that were
awesome but I did not leave
undergraduate knowing anything like that
that I feel like is like the the dream
that your parents sort of sell you and
that you know like for my mom or my dad
for example going to college was this
thing where maybe necessarily their
parents didn't go to college this is
like something that for our parents
generation was like the coolest [ __ ]
thing ever finally you know more people
can afford to go to college and have an
education and have an experience with
their peers at that age and it's [ __ ]
rad and they really do discover who they
are but for our generation it was sort
of like well now that I've done with 12
years of school let's go to
or [ __ ] Mar you know because that's
what I need to do in order to get an
entry-level job in this world like there
is no competing I mean there is through
totally exceptions but you know what I'm
saying that's sort of the expectation
and so our parents were giving this us
this romantic idea of Education of it
being like this wonderful time will you
discover yourself and blah blah blah
I don't know like I left undergraduate
just like [ __ ] confused as hell like
didn't know what I wanted to do didn't
really know anything except that my
education wasn't done and that was sort
of what drove me to apply to graduate
school and to pursue psychology sports
psychology because that's what my life
consisted of at the time and I was very
interested in it and I definitely would
have enjoyed working in that field I
believe if I hadn't taken a weird path
over here but it I definitely didn't
leave undergraduate being like I'm ready
for the world you know like I feel like
that's across the board know so many
young people leave undergraduate almost
more [ __ ] confused than they were on
their way and you know like who's on
your way in you're like I'm gonna have
the greatest four years ever and then
you're like dude this is a lot of work
and I don't I don't know what to do and
I know ones accepting my resume I don't
like you know it's kind of a [ __ ]
mess but my I think the most important
experiences that I had where social like
learning where you fit into a group what
your role is that kind of thing like
what kind of person are you are you a
leader do you like to be led are you
like if you're me like are you the
person that really just doesn't take
stuff that seriously like that was an
important lesson for me to learn about
myself was that sometimes if I don't
deem something to be like the biggest
[ __ ] deal even if everyone else
around me is like I'm just gonna have
fun you know and I did that I did is a
good thing to learn you know and just I
don't know that stupid stuff really
isn't that important and I remember
going to school I was 17 when I
graduated high school and I believe
birthday and I
went to school and I celebrated my 18th
birthday by laying on my dorm bed alone
doing nothing because I hadn't made any
friends yet and I had a roommate that we
were both like you know 18 and 17 and
I'm super excited we lived in a double
so it was just me and her and I'm like
I'm so excited to get to know my
roommate like hopefully she's like my
best friend is gonna be super great she
walks in with her boyfriend this is no
shade to her she was a really nice girl
and we wound up we were friends but like
we made great roommates because we
weren't like the closest friends ever
you know so this isn't shade to her but
like she walks in and she's like this is
my boyfriend blank and I'm like sick
dude nice to meet you and I was like way
to say like how old are you and he was
like I'm like 32 or whatever which to me
I'm like that age now but when you're
like 17 or 18 you're like dude what is
this [ __ ] grown man doing here dawg
like are you okay
like Disney sign you in like are you
supposed to be here Lee are you a
teacher I'm just like this is my
boyfriend like sag did [ __ ] great but
he apparently got kicked out of the dorm
that day because he had already tried to
smuggle in alcohol into my roommates
belongings like into her boxes which
apparently a lot of people do and he's
just like are it's not that we had a dry
campus my college was sort of like you
know a couple of buildings within the
city two of which were dorms and like
only out-of-state people were guaranteed
housing for two years only and then
after that but that's what I liked about
the school is that you're gonna end up
living in the city and you're not on a
campus because I never had that sort of
like I never wanted to be a campus thing
I don't know it just made me feel weird
I just wanted to live in a city you know
so he gets kicked out like the first day
the moving in day
it like [ __ ] super sorry that your
boyfriend got kicked out and he can't
come back because he's like 30 and just
tried to smuggle in alcohol like I get
it we're in college like I know we're
probably gonna [ __ ] drink and [ __ ] but
like
oh [ __ ] man your boyfriend has got
kicked out so I wound up being like a
sort of whatever thing because she would
leave Wednesday afternoons and returned
Monday mornings because she would go
stay at his place since he wasn't
allowed to come visit her so I basically
had a single dorm
you know Wednesday night Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday and then she would come
back so that was the other reason why we
got along so great it's because we
didn't really have to see each other
that much you know I'm saying but yeah
anyways I feel like all of my my best
experiences my most memorable
experiences really had nothing to do
with school or figure out who I was and
maybe that's not everyone's experience a
lot of people like I'm sure if you asked
my brother probably parts of his
experience where he had great mentors or
teachers or something I I'd like pretty
good teachers pretty decent teachers but
I didn't have like a mentor that sort of
changed my life or perspective until I
went to graduate school which was I
applied specifically because I really
admired this woman and her work and she
just was like everything to me and then
she wound up being that for me you know
what I mean like it's like meeting one
of your idols sort of but I didn't
idolize her but I really looked up to
her in a professional sense and I got
accepted into the school and just like
walking in the first day and like seeing
her in real life was like
it's [ __ ] magical and then you're
like alright well what's the catch maybe
she's like you know one of these
professors that think they're really
[ __ ] important which I had plenty of
those and you know the first thing they
do and your class is like assign you
four of their own books that they've
written and here's just like damn dude
[ __ ] there's and there's some other
important stuff out there that maybe you
didn't write that would be valuable to
our experience as students but you know
even whatever I'll buy all of your
[ __ ] books she wasn't like that she
was even more wonderful as I got a
chance to work with her which was
incredible so I guess I hope that for
people going off to school you keep your
expectations realistic like maybe you
lay on your dorm bed on your 18th
birthday and
no friends because you haven't really
found your tribe yet and you will but
that does take some effort and you don't
have this super romantic idea that
you're gonna come out with the best
friends you've ever had in your life
you have your life all figured out and
you have applied to a job that's gonna
pay you a comfortable salary that you're
gonna stay at for the rest of your life
like that's not that's not a thing
really anymore you know maybe for a
handful of people but I'd say the
majority of people coming out of
undergraduate are either like okay well
I either I need to go to graduate school
because everything's still outrageously
competitive with this level of education
or I need to take some time off go work
I need to take a job that has nothing to
do with what I studied in school and try
and figure my way out you know our way
up sorry and I feel like that's becoming
more and more common because an
undergraduate degree is no longer this
like all right you're solidified now in
this field it's sort of like you have a
basic understanding of how to be an
adult sort of you're still gonna have to
learn how to turn your taxes and take
care of yourself all on your own but
it's sort of just like a welcome to
adulthood get [ __ ] like everybody yeah
yeah sorry that was a very long winded
answer of information and experiences
that I learned none of which were really
academic I guess the only thing I did
learn that was academic was when I was
confused about what major I wanted to
pursue I asked my mom my adviser Emily
you know what should I do and they were
like we'll take one class of each so I
was interested in either like media and
that kind of thing or psychology so I
did it took one class in each I took a
mass media class and an entry at like a
intro to psychology and people in my
media class are still [ __ ] and
sufferable that I left I mean I finished
the class I got a grade but I was like
never again let's do psychology doesn't
call it a day I feel like a lot of
people stress about what they should
major in and you know that that's gonna
define the rest of your life and I mean
I'm sure it could but it also couldn't
you know as long as you're studying
something that you enjoy and you like I
don't think that that's a waste of time
or
as long as you're getting an education
for it you know like there's more debate
there about whether or not colleges
should be as expensive as they are or
for certain things like it's a weird
area if you know what I mean but as long
as you're enjoying yourself and you're
getting what you want out of that
experience and you're learning something
that's interesting to you I feel like
for a lot of people you're gonna leave
school and you just you're gonna have to
figure stuff out anyways though you
might as well have a degree in something
that was really [ __ ] fantastic can
you know what I'm thinking like I've had
people tweeting me about art school and
I don't know the first thing about art
school you know so I feel like there's
probably someone that could give you a
better answer than I could but for
something liberal art see you got a
psychology degree [ __ ] it man I don't
care
let's go study it'll be great I'll
figure it out later
maybe that's terrible advice but that's
what I did and I found it to be really
enjoyable I don't know I don't know
should I know anyways I've answered all
of like three questions but guess what I
don't have a fire segue but this week's
podcast has been sponsored by
Squarespace I'm so bad at this oh I feel
so inadequate without my Julie Oh
Squarespace is good enough for Keanu
Reeves John Malkovich and and just so
many other people it's good enough for
you okay just like a liberal arts degree
it's good enough for you that doesn't
even make any sense I really need Julian
you know a dream is just a great idea
that doesn't have a website yet make it
a reality at squarespace.com slash Jenna
Julianne their templates make creating
an online identity super easy and every
template is a starting point for a wide
range of projects plus it's all in one
platform there's nothing to install
patch or upgrade ever in Squarespace is
the most amazing award-winning 24/7
customer support you won't be fumbling
around
wondering how the hell to get your
website done because you can call them
at 2:00 a.m. when you're eating pizza me
you know
keep dreaming but make it a reality with
a website from Squarespace head to
Squarespace comm / Jenna Julian and get
10% off your first person purchase of a
website or a domain that squarespace.com
slash Jenna Julian and this podcast is
also brought to you by me undies which
I'm wearing right now they're like a
white rosy pad and the really cute
you want to feel naked but not naked get
yourself me undies the ultimate
feel-good underwear made from is a
sustainably sourced natural soft fabric
that's three times softer than cotton me
undies will be the most comfy undies you
will ever own and I can vouch for that
because not entire underwear drawer is
full of girls for you they come in tons
of different colors styles solids lace
boy shorts bikini thong there's
something for everyone I you know like
the expensive Victoria's Secret ones
with like the least and their thong me
honey's makes those except they're
softer and they last longer you know
what I'm saying and for guys the diamond
seam pouch gives you this stuff the your
stuff the support it needs without
feeling too tight I'm gonna take their
word for that and I I just I love my me
undies they're pretty fantastic Julian
loves his too and my favorite is when
our patterns match each other because
we're gross like that you know sometimes
it's fun to just have the undies is so
sure you will love their underwear they
offer a hundred cents size so I
shouldn't guarantee if you don't love
your first pair get a full refund right
now ding p.m. get 20% off your first
pair and free shipping there's a
no-brainer to go to Mia news.com 20% off
free shipping hundred-percent
satisfaction guarantee what are you
waiting for to get your 20% off and
shipping free and their hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee to be the softest
under Eve of ever owned me undies calm /
jenna julie and that's me Andy
calm / Jenna Julian thank you so much
sponsors and thank you for putting up
with me because I'm not as good as
Julian this is why we've we've
established this relationship with
Julian he reads the sponsors because he
really just has the gift you know what
I'm saying
anyways back to you all the questions
I'm such a blabbermouth
as I've literally answered three
questions wrap it up Jenni you can do it
concise it down how about you talk about
all of your favorite memories of Julian
so if he's not doing okay at the moment
he can watch the podcast and smile our
I'm gonna cry I like there's too many
like favorite moments of Julian there's
just too many like he's just the best
he's just the best like he's just the
best I'm trying to think of like one or
two he did something funny the other day
that I wish I could remember I don't
know it's just I'm I'm like flooded with
everything fun and funny and these last
like few days have been really difficult
because as you like you a lot of you
guys watched Julian's vlogs and like I
think you have a pretty solid
understanding of us as people for the
most part and we spend a lot of our time
just like laughing just laughing and
like stupid stuff making each other
laugh and it's been really difficult to
not hear Julian laugh for days you know
and for a lot of people when when stuff
happens in their life that could be a
really long time and you just don't hear
someone laugh or like see them smile so
that's that sucked you know to not hear
him laugh so if you guys have anything
fun or funny to send over to Julian
please do that because you know when
you're going through something weird and
hard this is what we did when we watch
Coco it's like you know you have these
moments of like I need to be sad right
now and then you have these moments of
like I just
distraction so if you could just
distract them for a little bit for the
next time when he locks onto Twitter and
there's a bunch of funny gifts that'd be
fantastic because I do think everyone
just needs moments of distraction and
this like the common waves you know this
like see you're okay and then you're not
okay and then you're okay and then
you're not okay you know what I'm saying
oh boy my Julie I don't know there's
just too much to pick I love everything
about Julian I hope everything is okay
and a good idea could be what are your
plans for the future and what you would
likely be doing if YouTube didn't work
out I feel like that's a pretty common
question that people ask me the answer
the second part I would probably be
working in some context in my field in
sports psychology but I'd probably be
working with kids I mean I spend a lot
of time in my life working with kids I
work to the Boys and Girls Club for
years it's like I don't know I was a
camp counselor before that for all the
way through college and then after
college I would work to the Boys and
Girls Club and stuff and uh it's just
like I don't know it's just something
that's easy for me to to do I feel like
when I was a kid you know something I
would scream yell at my mom was like
sometimes you forget how hard it is be a
kid like I remember saying this my mom
and like you get to go to work everyday
and like ain't what you want for lunch
and like you know you get to do
something that you like doing I just go
to school every day and people talk to
me it's so boring and I hate it and like
I remember multiple times my life having
those moments of like I need an adult to
just remember how much sometimes it just
sucks to be a kid and not like a child
like as a young human just like trying
to make sense of everything and like at
the same time feeling like all these
firsts that happen to you like the first
time that your friend lies to you or
like you know something stupid like that
it's just you've never had that happen
before
so everything sucks all the time oh
you're like going through this
terrifying awful roller coaster and
everything that you're learning is
getting harder look used to just be like
I'm building blocks today and like
coloring a coloring book and all of a
sudden I'm doing [ __ ] and I [ __ ] I
wasn't paying attention the other day
you know I'm totally lost
and I'm [ __ ] right now and then I have
to go to gym later and we're playing
soccer and I'm not gifted at it and it
makes me feel and how to quit I also
don't like my gym outfit and I'm not in
a class but I met friends it sucks you
know it's like a series of suck and like
firsts and then a series of like feeling
really good about yourself
and then not good about yourself and I
just feel like when I worked with kids
it wasn't because I've had so many
moments of like remembering and really
being in touch with myself when I was a
kid and like thinking about how
frustrated it was that some of those
things it wasn't difficult for me to
work with kids for as long as I did or
will in the future because it's like I
get it man like I get it I'm not trying
to get you to be a [ __ ] a tiny adult
I'm not like you're going through some
suck stuff okay and your pain is valid
and your frustration is valid you need
some suck stuff but it's gonna be okay
you know kids are also very easy to
distract like what saying about Julian
like it's not just that and sometimes
you need times to be sad and other times
you need times to be distracted and just
have some fun for a little bit so
anyways I would probably be working with
kids answer your question
Kermit thank you for snoring oh he's
like out man and my plans for the future
someone had tweeted at me I feel like
you know for the most part all of you
guys are really really really nice to
Julian and I about our relationship and
I don't I made a video forever ago years
ago about how marriage isn't super
important to me and I I don't know it's
just not something that I care about and
all that matters is the commitment to me
and that could change in the future or I
don't it's just whatever I don't know I
just don't
it's not like top of my priority list
you know like top of my priority list
any given day is like wake up and feed
the dogs and like put my contacts in and
then the rest of it I'm like this is
fine I don't know if that makes any
sense it's not a super priority to me
but for us we'd like to buy a house and
have that be like our roots I think once
we do that we can start you know doing
all the rest of the things in life that
we'd like to do but we'd like to put
down some roots and actually have a
place that we own that we can work out
of yeah I think for the future that's
that's our short and long-term goal is
to get a house move in which is no easy
process and then see sort of where life
takes us from there so that's sort of
what I'm focusing on right now
and Julian as well I mean I'm not gonna
speak for Julian he's not here but I
think so
I think we're on the same page Lindsey
well asked advice on balancing things in
your life like for me it's school sports
friends and online things like twitch
and online friends and I'm not balancing
it too well at the moment oh girl you a
preaching to the choir I will say one
thing I don't know how old you are but
when I was younger I had limited sort of
online capabilities because there was no
like YouTube had just started and it
wasn't really a popular thing and I
wasn't making YouTube videos like when I
was in college it was like I might watch
an episode of Flavor of Love you know
sorry for ageing myself but it's true
like there's only so much I could do
that wasn't like texting someone or
talking on the phone with someone or
like I don't know like we got me my
roommate would go on this website called
stupid videos and I maybe this is a
better answer I'm getting there
bear with me me and my roommate used to
go on this website called stupid videos
and it was just it's sort of like
Yvonne's world but like stupider because
they were all just stupid videos so
basically like what YouTube was and
infancy stupid videos was that but like
you couldn't upload to it you know it
was just it was a big collection of
stupid videos and we would go on there
and we would spend [ __ ] hours sitting
in my room dying laughing and my best
friend Jackie who you guys have seen in
one of my videos like I went to her
wedding whatever and um she just has
like a different sense of humor like you
know people that don't like get internet
humor or like they don't think there's
have a different sense of humor than you
do and she would come in there it's like
you guys been watching this [ __ ] for
hours for hours I don't get it and we're
like dude you have to watch this this is
the funniest [ __ ] thing I've ever
seen and it's like a bunch of guys
running an inflatable car into traffic
like not hurting themselves they're just
running it on to a meme wrote whatever
she's like I don't get it that's not
funny
that's stupid and I'm like yeah I know
it's stupid videos it's great should
come and watch with us sometime - a lot
of people that is a gigantic [ __ ]
waste of time
but what I feel like happened was I
found my true passion in life which was
just laughing at [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying I mean it's a little ironic now
that I mean I went through graduate
school I did all of that and what do I
do
i watch hours of stupid videos and I
participate in the making of the stupid
videos so in theory was it a waste of
time I don't know I would say in terms
of balancing things what I used to do
was priority number one was always
making sure that everything actually got
done so if I had a paper or something
like I'm a procrastinator I've always
been a procrastinator but like a not a
terrible one you know I'm not gonna turn
in a piece of [ __ ] like I'm gonna work
on it I'm gonna make sure it gets done
but like I'm not that kid that has it
done for [ __ ] days in advance
okay I'm not like I was never like that
no no shame if you are good for you I
just wasn't but like I would reward
myself you know I would work on my paper
for a couple hours and then I would
reward myself by watching like an
episode of Flavor of Love you know I
mean we started
give and take system and I feel like if
you're looking for that balance just
make sure if your stuff is done it's
time to do whatever the [ __ ] you want
and none of that time to me is wasted
and for you maybe it's twitch and
hanging out with your friends online and
doing that stuff and trust me there's
plenty of procrastination that can go on
you can do it here and there but if your
stuff is done go enjoy yourself and do
whatever it is that you like as long as
it's not hurting anybody or you know
it's putting negative [ __ ] into the
world like if it's watching people on
Twitch or like painting or laughing at
stupid videos like it's your free time
go do what you want but I'd say use
those as a tool to reward yourself to
get your [ __ ] done you know what I'm
saying and try and create that system
for yourself otherwise nothing gets done
and then you get in that cycle of like
feeling bad and then I didn't do my
stuff but I'm sitting here doing this
instead you know what I mean like even
as an adult I find myself still doing
this like why can't my video done on
Wednesdays I'm like sick yes all right
uploaded it's time to play a game of
hearthstone baby wanted to play all day
baby I still do it I don't know it works
for me but I mean also to give you a
little bit of perspective though to like
school sports friends online things like
twitch and online friends that's a lot
you know you're a talented young lady
and I promise you like later in life
sometime when it's not as much you'll be
like wow I really was a magician back I
don't know I feel like I balance things
like a relationship taking care of
animals taking care of my house cleaning
cooking those kinds of things like the
balancing never goes away but like I
promise you that the some of the the
stress of it you know gets a little
easier if that makes sense I don't know
about kids I feel like that gets way
harder so it gets easier for a little
while and then it gets way harder
whatever you get the point
oh you guys the funny oh my god I need
some advice for my aunt Jenna about how
to motivate myself okay here's something
interesting there's an in sport
psychology there's a lot of really
interesting Studies on well everything
because all of it's fascinating to me
but motivation is one of those
interesting things where there's a lot
of literature on and it's really
interesting thing to study because like
where does this thing come from why why
are some people more motivated at some
things than other things and you know
what makes motivation happen what
motivates you to sort of a profound
thing who it has a lot of answers but to
me I think a tangible piece of advice
that I could give you for motivation is
maybe not like all the internal things
sort of think that you probably have to
discover for yourself but something that
helps me everyday is to just get a
positive ball rolling so like in the
morning if it's just like I'm gonna make
myself a smoothie you know maybe you
have a leftover piece of pizza and you
could eat that Pizza Pizza but like if I
start my day off with like a smoothie
all right good
I'm feeling good then maybe I'll take
the dogs for a walk around the block all
right well now that I've gotten those
things done I'm feeling pretty good
about myself and then you end up doing
multiple more things that are at least
productive in the right direction then
you would have a feud laid in bed and
like looked at Twitter and looked at
Instagram and then like I'm talking
about like a day off not like a day we
have to go to school or something I
don't know I don't know you know what
I'm saying if you get a positive ball
rolling early in your day the chances of
you continuing to move that ball
throughout the rest of your day and do
things that you probably don't even want
to do are much higher in my experience
than the days when you just can't do a
[ __ ] thing and those days serve a
purpose trust me they need to exist
they're totally there for a reason
take those days and don't feel bad about
them but on the days when you'd like to
get some stuff don't like just do one or
two simple things in the morning
and it will sometimes hopefully for the
most part in my experience they do
translate into like a bigger snowball
that snowballs then through the rest of
your day to help you do more productive
things throughout the day I don't know
that's one of my only tangible pieces of
advice for motivation because motivation
is really complicated and there's a lot
of cool stuff on the internet you could
read about it if you interested
[Music]
tips on becoming a vegan yeah um I have
a weird vegan journey not really but
sort of but like when when I first
started how ever long ago eight I'm
[ __ ] them not eight years ago it was
a plant-based diet I was eating plants
plant-based that like I was eating meat
one day a week and that was because I
liked the way that it made me feel I had
done some research on my shitty internet
that I had at the time which I mean it
took a very long time just to get
limited information but yeah I just did
some research and I was like that seems
cool I'd be interested in trying that
and I did and then I would eat meat one
day a week is like my cheat meal and I
felt great I think that that was the
beginning of my plant-based diet because
it was not ethically driven and then
time went on I went back to eating meat
and I also went back to not feeling very
good I think a lot of it just comes from
like listening to your body and
listening to what it needs and what
feels good and then as time went on I
was like eating me is really it was
making me feel weird like I I think it's
what's described as brain fog but I
there were so many times when I told
Julian like I can't think I can't think
I don't have any thoughts there's
nothing there's nothing there nothing is
happening I'm having no thoughts it's
really frustrating and I was also
feeling pretty tired and I had tried
being vegetarian which didn't really
work for me it made me feel also tired
and not great I don't know why and we're
talking about very small levels of
difference and tired because then you
know taking vitamins and supplements as
well during all of this
and then I finally watched sad stuff and
Julian didn't go through this process
he's probably the only person that is a
vegan that I've seen successfully
transitioned and not go through that
process but for me I was like happy
being plant-based I really like that but
I didn't really see a problem with
eating meat and you know I was raised
eating meat and everyone around me ate
meat and dairy and didn't really see a
problem and then I watched the sad stuff
and I only needed like a day of it and
what I did was actually so embarrassing
Julian I think I forget where he went he
was somewhere gone all day and I forced
myself to watch like you know a solid
afternoon like a solid three or four
hours worth of just sad animal stuff and
I sat there in the couch I was sobbing
and sobbing and sobbing and sobbing and
sobbing and that was it like I haven't
seen a lot of the vegan documentaries I
haven't seen a lot of the like you know
more famous movies about it and that was
it I was all I needed and I was like I
don't I just don't I don't want to
contribute to that and just stop and
that was it so I'd say if you want to
become a vegan a if you have a choice
about what you're eating watch them
search it if you're a teenager I get
this question a lot if you're a teenager
whose family household you know is being
shopped for by the your parents or
something I no one is mad at you for
eating the food that is being provided
for you and if you're interested in not
eating meat or anything like that how
you know have conversations with your
parents but like understand that maybe
your parents don't care that you want to
be a vegan maybe maybe they don't want
to cater to that and when some day when
you do have a choice about what you get
to eat you can make those choices when
you're an adult because food is a very
personal thing food is also an expensive
thing and it's really difficult for some
families to accommodate different diets
you know especially since being vegan is
a choice whereas maybe like Julian
celiac disease that's not a choice like
your it's like being allergic to peanuts
and your parents are like eat these
[ __ ] peanuts and you're like mom I'm
gonna die like if you would like to be a
vegan in your 13 years old and your
parents won't help you do that and don't
support you you don't need to be upset
at them just keep going keep trying the
best that you can keep learning and and
what someday when you have control over
what you can eat and this is your money
going into what you eat and your choices
you can make those choices but you I've
read a lot of things like I you know I
[ __ ] hate my mom cuz she won't let me
do this and it's like respect your mom
always number two your mom is like
losing her [ __ ] mind sometimes okay
she's very overwhelmed she loves you
very much she just wants to feed you the
six recipes she knows how to make okay
you know someday when you get to decide
what goes into your body all the time
you can make those choices but like you
don't need to hate your mom okay she
loves you it's gonna be okay but other
than that if you do have a choice about
what goes in your body and you're
interested in becoming a vegan
I'd say watch them sad [ __ ] or try some
vegan recipes like Julian's way of
becoming a vegan was watching me cook
delicious food and being really jealous
about it
so I'd say try cooking some stuff and
just see that it's pretty delicious and
anything that you like to eat you could
probably make without animal products
and if you like it get into it watch
some sad [ __ ]
what not those are my tips and don't be
frustrated with yourself like just try
your best
and your best is always good enough when
it comes to putting in effort and trying
there's like a lot of learning I feel
like as you get more into being vegan
there's a lot of stuff you need to know
about like what your body needs I had to
take care of that whatever but like if
you're just trying just know that you're
gonna make mistakes you're gonna [ __ ] up
you're gonna be confused you're gonna
not know what to make you're gonna be
like I don't know what to do like it's a
learning process and just do the best
that you can be patient with yourself
have faith and the
you know you're doing something that
feels good for your body if it does it
does and if it doesn't I don't know
you'd figure something out you know I'm
saying I don't know do it feels what's
right for you all right
that was very long-winded answer I'm
very sorry
what do you do when you're in love with
someone they don't love you back but you
can't shake the crush please help those
from Lexie oh ok here's my advice coming
from personal experience as someone that
had a crush on a boy like all of six and
seventh grade I think I told the story
before about how I would wait at his
locker every morning before homeroom and
I had a fifty-two tardies in one quarter
which was only made up of like 60 or 70
days or something
I was late 52 of those days because I
was waiting for this boy at his locker
and we were friends but like he didn't
like me back you know I basically just
kept liking him until I found another
boy depending how old you are I'd say if
you were in middle school like go ahead
and like that boy it sucks like I it
sucks you know to like someone that
doesn't like you back there's nothing
wrong with liking them like it sucked
when he would like had a girlfriend then
I was like I wish she would ask me the
dance but he doesn't like me
this sucks I'll still wait for him in
his locker but then eventually like I
started to hang out with other boys and
then I had another boyfriend you know
and that was sort of the end of it was
like hanging out with another boy or a
person or whoever it is that you like
just spend some time with other people
because that boy or girl doesn't like
you back and you're allowed to still
like them that's where this not shaking
the crush comes from but I think that
you will meet someone that makes it a
lot easier for you to just be like well
it's your loss because I've been waiting
and you like every single day and you
don't care that I'm here but I've been
here it's not over it still is it and
then they kiss like in the notebook but
that
that just never happens because they
didn't like you back you know me is [ __ ]
anyways I say just keep living your life
keep living your life you can like them
but you'll find somebody that actually
appreciates how much you like them you
know what I'm saying there's so many
questions tell us about how you've
managed what seems like the healthiest
most perfect relationship with Julian
well first of all me and Julian to not
have a perfect relationship I think you
guys all know that for real like we have
a serious true relationship we fight all
the time especially since we work
together and we work in multiple
capacities together we stream live
together we have a podcast together and
he helps me every week with my videos
and I'm you know often in his vlogs
because his vlogs are about his life so
there's a lot of communication that goes
into it and I really feel like with me
and Julian or in like a relationship in
general my perspective is that love
grows over time and you're strengthens
in your relationship with someone grows
over time so you know when we first
started dating there are a lot of
obstacles like the fact that I'm six
years older than him and there were
things that I was like this is stupid
like I am too old for this [ __ ] you know
and for him it was like you're too old
for this [ __ ] and I'm like [ __ ] you dumb
stuff you know what I'm saying
you have obstacles but the more time
that you spend together and spend
working through those things or past
those things the stronger your
relationship becomes so I feel like
we're at a very good point in our at
least working loving living life
situation where we've gotten a really
good system of communication going where
we can hear each other and we can talk
about things as they're happening not
once someone is upset about them and
because we have to work together so many
times during the week like you can't let
things Fester
or you know
do that grow inside of you and make you
upset and bottle up like it you can't do
that we have to hash it out and get it
figured out because you know we got a
podcast later I need to shoot a video
where I'm filming a vlog today of the
house so can you please tell me what's
going on and then we can work it out and
move past it thank you so in a way I
think that it has helped us to work
together because you know we got a
figure stuff out or else nothing's gonna
get done like you can go powder around
the house and be upset and me too and we
can just pretend like we're in a big
fight or we could just figure it out you
know so I feel like our relationship is
really strong because we communicate
with each other a lot we have to and we
listen to each other and we spend a lot
of time investing in each other if that
makes sense
like some people are really good at
stuff or have invested a lot of time
into a certain hobby I feel like it
takes a lot of time and energy and work
and love and care and why pairing and
they're trying to get your relationship
in a place that's really good and it
takes a lot to maintain that and I think
a lot of people would agree that are
married or in serious long relationships
is what I've heard from people is like
this is a lot of work and you got to
work at it every single day and it's
really nice to have that work sort of
payoff because you get to spend time
with someone that you truly love and
it's wonderful to be around and there's
your best friend you get your best
friend out of that and so no way I mean
we don't have a perfect relationship at
all and we continue to go through things
together but that tests our bond and our
friendship and our relationship and our
working relationship and as long as both
parties are willing to hear each other
and listen to each other and work
through those things like as fast as you
can you know not in an insensitively
fast way but I'm saying as opposed to
letting them drag out like with like we
got to figure it out because we got to
get back to the love and the happy
because that's that's all we're here for
right like we're here for the love and
the happy
let's let's get back there I need to
know what what's wrong in order for us
to make that better and fix it and it
takes a lot of energy and effort to fix
the things like it's not easy to have
someone that you love so they tell you
like everything that you're doing that's
wrong and you're like did it [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know and then you got to work on
those things or else you're not gonna be
in a happy relationship but I don't know
I feel like it seems like I can imagine
why it seems like we have a really great
relationship because you guys do it's
not like we sit and record our [ __ ]
arguments but I promise you there are
plenty of them and we handle them in a
civilized manner I mean sometimes you
gotta just like yell and scream and
[ __ ] whatever it is but it's not
dramatic you know it's like a there's
plenty of vlogs I feel like where I'm at
that level of like Julia that one you
get there but like never in a place
where you're gonna hurt each other like
emotionally verbally you know what I
mean that's not productive
none of that um but yeah I feel like we
spend a lot of time making sure that
we're being the best partner for each
other that we can and it's not a perfect
relationship it takes a lot of work so
that's the secret it just takes a lot of
[ __ ] work just like everything
[ __ ] else
no I'm saying Kermit right Kermit
Kermit's a lot of work he's taking a lot
of pills lately ever since you
dislocated your little kneecap my poor
bud but yeah I mean that's I guess the
podcast they didn't get to any
misconnections because I've been
blabbering the entire time I've also
blacked out for most of this I bloated
cuz it's kind of hot in here and it's
weird to just do a podcast by yourself
you know I really miss Julian hopefully
he'll be back next week but also we're
gonna be patient with him we're gonna
give Julian as much time as he needs I
hope you're on board with that if for
some reason he was not down to do this
next week I will find a guest host so
if it comes to that it won't just be
another hour of me rambling I appreciate
all of you for putting up with me in
this for this long if you've made it
this far but yeah if you have anything
funny or sweet or nice to San Julian's
way I think that would be much
appreciated and we love him and miss him
and you know what's weird all right
thanks so much for watching listening
and I'll see you guys next week
[Music]
[Music]